the next biggest case hooker Fuji and
he's going to talk about separations
even in the presence of noise thank you
okay okay me okay my name is Casey Fuji
from the University Batoka and today I
want to talk about the facial serum for
quantum spray maseeh or we should say
quantum ascendancy following the talk
given by profits each an eye on Tuesday
but anyway here we interesting in the
hardness of classical simulation of
noisy a quantum circuits especially we
are interested in the very noisy case
where we cannot affirm universe a fall
trend quantum computation but even in
such a case we can find we can find a
special value without which we can find
a quantum advantage against classical
computer so this is all trying of this
talk I want to first talk about
motivation of studying noisy quantum
circuits and then I want to explain how
to show hardness and then I will explain
our main reserved special Salem for
quantum splicing and then apply this
result to complete a scheme like a 3d
topological cross the state competition
and also to the a faltering competition
with surface good okay hey fast
motivation so phantoms premises was
stated by a professor John bicycle in
the Solvay conference in 2011 and he
asked that how can we best achieve
quantum supremacy
with the relatively small system that
may be experimentally accessible very
soon with hundred cubits and actually as
you know recently extended paid to
realize experiment the quantum devices
book in quantum information processing
and so now more and more accurate a
quantum operation are realized and also
more and more number of qubits are
available so now it's a good time to
argue how to demonstrate is the quantum
advantage over the classical computer
and this is nicely also introduced by
the previous talk by Sergio and for this
purpose there are several intermediate
models for quantum computation here
intermediate means that it's a it's not
universal but see we can find some are
quantum advantage against classical
computer one example is the bottom
sampling have proposed by islands and
irish pub and another is the IQ p which
consists of the commuting socket like
here a problem proposed by bremner jos
on shabbat and another example is the
dtc one model this is a highly mixed
state quantum competition with one clean
cubed and all these intermediate models
not a universal but physically
experimentally very motivated this is
because boson samplings is nothing but a
linear optical quantum computation and
already we have several experimental
demonstrations and also i QP is can be
implemented by using a Hamiltonian
dynamics with easing type interaction
and
also dtc one is a model of quantum
computation using NMR spin ensemble so
in this sense these all models are
physically very motivated and the main
purpose of this study this work is to
add a new item to these intubating
immediate models namely universal socket
but as a circuit is very noisy so
basically really interested in very very
noisy lesion where we cannot perform a
standard for Trenton universal quantum
computation so the motivation
considering noisy quantum socket is here
so there is ongoing project on 22 which
aims for torrent universal quantum
competition his IBM and a delta to take
and john martin smith google and all
these projects the target of all this
project is a special cell line and three
so salem state that if the noise
strength is more than smaller than a
certain special value then you can
perform universal quantum computation
with an arbitrary accuracy right so here
we have a threshold value and a bit of
which we can perform in the bus at
quantum computation and special value
highly depends on the module fortran
scheme and also depends on the choice of
the noise model and speech cliff which
is a political forint quantum
computation on the speed across estate
or two-dimensional foreign competition
with surface good then a father if we
choose a noise as a phenomenal annoyed
model then special value is given
something like a three percent and if on
the other hand if we choose a socket
based noise model which is a more
realistic
it's model where each element our gate
is followed by some depolarizing noise
in such a case we have a special value
which is something like one passing and
here we have a very natural question so
can we simulate the noisy quantum system
above this racial body so this is very
natural question but the answer is
somehow not assault oliviero but at
least we can say that in the phenomenal
normal ill and the noise rate is higher
than 14.6 passing then we can fully
simulate the system by using go Desmond
New Salem this is because if noise level
is higher than this value then the magic
state a becomes a complex mixture of
power base state so in this sense we can
simulate in this vision but still we
here have a large gap between the
quantum and classical simulation
simulate able lesions and one of the
main motivation of this work is to
characterize these intermediate lesion
ok so let's move on to the how to show
hardness in our proof so we use a post
selected quantum computation so the
ideal postulate also post directed
competition is to solve decision problem
by using conditional probability
distribution so suppose we have a is a
quantum or a classical plastic computer
here here we have two kinds of out of it
out of texts used to solve the disc bomb
problem and they hear another outfit y
and this output is to use post-sex some
very rare event and we solve the
decision problem by using this
conditional probability distribution
conditional on the y equal one the
important thing here is the probability
or position can be exponentially small
right so you might think
this is somehow cheating because a
actually experimental situation we
cannot perform this kind of
post-election but still this perception
is useful to distinguish your system is
quantum or Glasgow so so actually if you
apply a post-election to the classical
system the system is resulting in the
post BBB+ the result in the possibility
p on the other hand if your system is
quantum then you apply plus section you
result in the possibility P and Allison
showed that post be QP is equal to P P P
P is the prophecy polynomial computation
which is a one of the kruskal complexity
class and now here we have a classical
computational class and another
classical competition plus that we can
compare directory competitive to class
by using the polynomial hiroyuki the
polynomial heroic is a natural extension
of energy problem NP problem by using a
local machine and now post bpp ap Loco p
with a la cama simple bpp is included in
the subtle level of the polynomial
hierarchy on the other hand p with PP
machine okuma seen a include whole of
the polynomial hierarchy so this
indicates that if these two plus a
equivalent equivalent then polynomial
here Ricky cost to the third level so
this indicates that if you are your
system is potentially as powers both
possibility p under the post section
then your system cannot be simulated
efficiently on the classical computer
unless the polynomial here our kickoff
to subweb so this is very nice and
useful way to show some
quantum system is hard for classical
computer to simulate but there is a
subtle point here in this hardness proof
we require some how strong stolen notion
of sampling like a multiplicative era
sampling with multiplicative error like
this so this is a sample probability
distributions this is ideal property
distribution and here we have a some
constant rather than one so this is
somehow somehow a stolen notion of
sampling and this is Rita improved to
the sampling with constant additive era
with l1 norm or total variation distance
here but still this notion of sampling
is very strong so unfortunately if there
is a noise small amount of noise in your
quantum circuit then these conditions
are easily block so we we cannot apply
it this condition for a nosey quantum
socket so we need a new framework so
let's move on to the remaining result so
main idea is here so here we have a idea
of quantum target which we want to
simulate so here we again we have a to
outbid hair and conditional probability
distribution is used to solve a PP
complete problem and our idea is
simulate these this idea quantum circuit
by uz by using for Tremont version which
consists of the noisy sockets and output
is processed here by using some
classical algorithm then finally we
obtain is a logical outfit x and y which
simulate the idea one but here we should
remain
that we are basically interested in the
very noisy case where we cannot perform
falter and universal quantum computation
so we need another toeic so here we have
another output d which has a use
information about our sindelle and here
we use a post section on on d on the
error syndrome see here we choose a no
error syndrome is activated so by using
this conditional probability condition
on the new single measurement we
simulate this idea our socket and a lot
proof of special seldom consists of two
parts one part is to show exponentially
small a additive error between the ideal
one and simulated one is actually enough
to show hardness classical simulation of
this ultimate on XYZ and the second one
is actually we can achieve this
exponentially small additive area
between the idea of one similarity to
bomb by using arrow action under Section
ogre it see the fast fast in detail so
the first pass is a consist of follow so
we solve the pp complete problem special
we solve the majority SAT by using hey
this circuit ideal socket as done in the
Allison's work and in doing so we can
calculate a weekend lower bound the post
section probability by the exponential
small value here so by using this fact
we can show that if the distance between
the ideal and simulated one is
exponentially close then we can show
that conditional probability is also
us a very close actually is a distance a
the difference between these two
probability is smaller than 1 over ha
actually this is enough to solve a PP
complete problem by using this
probability distribution over X Y Z
right and next part so next part is how
to reduce the distance distance how to
this is the distance between the ideal
ideal and simulated one similarly
assimilated one and here we have a
quadrant quantum socket which includes
the classical processing and this
circuit consists of the sequence of
unitary gates here we have a idea
windigate UK and which followed by a
noisy one here we assume stochastic
noise which means that a which can be
divided into the ideal part identity
part and CPW month right and then a the
final output probably this television
all the XYZ is written in this form and
then this noisy a density matrix is
decomposed into this space land faulty
one here the sparse density matrix is
defined as such that under condition or
post section so neuro single measurement
the output probability distribution is
proportional to the ideal probability
distribution by using this definition we
can bounce the difference distance
between the idea and some rated output
by using the operator norm of the faulty
part which is divided by the probability
to eq probability Q is a probability to
to get a new swindle measurement so
provide to post select new single
measurement and the primary this value
can be evaluated evaluated by using the
Norns parameter epsilon and if epsilon
is smaller than some constant station
value then this value can be
exponentially small so finally we
conclude that there is a concentration
value bill Fitch as output from the
noisy quantum shock it can't be
simulated by using classical computer
unless the polynomial hiroaki cost is
hardware so let's apply a this result
here to the concrete models like 3d
topological krasa competition and
two-dimensional faltering computation
which surveys code so fast topological
measurement based quantum computation on
the 3d process take so here we employ a
measurement based computation on glass
state of degree log N and this question
today to the committing sockets of depth
send and also we apply a very simple
noise model so no it is an independent
single qubit dephasing with verbally te
and then the faulty part 40 operator is
decomposed into the two part one part is
the faulty a part question to the
clifford operations another is the
quality part question to the magic state
distillation and these two beta the
operational web these two operator can
be evaluated for example a cliff old
case we can bury it a the operator norm
by counting self avoiding walk and a
given like this and then we can
calculate this ratio value physically
fault pad like here so 0.1 67
and then we can also calculate the
threshold body for the magic magic state
distribution and it's actually given by
the zero point one four six because in
this direction magic state registration
is tight so so now you realize that the
threshold for Clifford operation is much
higher than the special for the magic
state the dispersion the special for the
quantum supremacy in this model is
dymond puri by the magic state D station
so which returned to the Israeli food
motivation so now we find that if the
probability is smaller than this special
for the magic state distribution the
secret crush relational system is hard
so in this sense we find that all region
in between universe and classical
simulation can be characterized
characterized as hard for classical
computer to simulate right then finally
I wanna apply this result for a socket
based noise model which will be more
interested in the experimentalists and
here we consider the two-dimensional
rattus and use surface curl and
two-dimensional nearest neighbor gates
on the square grid lattice and the noise
model is sucked based depolarizing noise
model so each preparation and
measurement and single qubit and two
cubed gates followed by the Sun
depolarizing noise with probability P
and in this case the things is slightly
complicated because we have a correlated
year so in this case we have to take
into account correlated error on their
artists but still we can model this
system as a phenomenological model by
crib re-defining
effective single qubit error late so
here we have an independent error rate a
new and collar ATT relate mu and by
defining these this barrier as a
effective single qubit error we can
model the system as phenomenon which got
Molly oh and by using this we can
calculate the threshold value in this
case and the resultant special value is
something like to point eighty four
percent and again in this case even in
this case this is damaged by the
disturbia t of magic state an important
thing here is this special is much
higher than the special for standard
universal falter and quantum computation
which is 0.75 percent obtained in the
same noise model so this query showed
that the the noisy quantum circuit which
is achieved in near future were already
achieved is enough to show a quantum
chemistry so quantum advantage against
classical computer so let's summarize
this Turk sorry whoops
okay rich summarize this talk so we show
that a noisy sampling from the noisy
quantum socket can exhibit quantum
supremacy is the noise rate is smaller
than some special value and this special
value field quantum supremacy is much
higher than the standard special value
for the universal phantom in Basle
faltering quantum computation and the
interesting point here is that the
special value for phantoms premise is
purely determined by the distributing of
magic state and it is somehow natural
because the magic state is necessary for
a university of quantum computation and
they so now it's very interesting to ask
how how can be a verify or directly
identify a such quantum supremacy noisy
quantum devices in near future so thank
you for attention thank you very much we
have time for six or seven questions in
the back hi yes I think I may have
missed so the many of the previous
quantum supremacy complexity theory
results rest on some conjectures you
know to establish that this bounded
error simulation would collapse
polynomial hierarchy what is the is
there a complexity theoretic conjecture
or is there a conjecture that you know
your your result assumes sorry so could
you could you say more rowdy oh I was
just wondering if this result rests on a
conjecture like for example the
conjectures that oh yes ssssss yes a
actually this result is based on the
conjecture that polynomial hierarchy
does not cross do the solder level but
there's no further conjectures like for
example in the Aronson paper there's
this
permanent of Gaussian I in this index
case we do not need another conjecture
thank you more questions I have a
question so you showed the threshold
result for universal computation I
wonder what happens if you restrict the
model say if you say you only have
logarithmic depth circuits or you have a
DQ see one circuit is it still true can
you still have a separation in the three
ah i see it's a very good question and
yay in iqp case with constant depth we
can I think we can derive the similar
special for quantum Spanish supremacy
but in the case of ditch one I think
it's very difficult that you divide some
threshold for quantum famously okay can
you elaborate why what's the
difficulties what's the difficulty in
such in the case of dickish you are
there is risk measurement board so we we
cannot use the toy for the posture
acting some new single measurement okay
so that's the reason why it's difficult
to delight the similar things for dt
supermodel understand more questions if
not let's thank our speaker again
you